[Musique]
aujourd'hui les gardiens de la paix en
des armes qui sont des pistolets
automatiques qui sont tout sauf discret
qui sont faits pour être porté à
l'extérieur dessus avec austère l
extérieur je vois je ne vois pas très
bien comment ces fonctionnaires vont
pouvoir ensuite entrer dans des
bâtiments publics santé cela se remarque
je ne suis pas convaincu que tous les
fonctionnaires de police
systématiquement vont sortir avec leurs
armes
parce que on n'a pas forcément besoin
son arme
quand on va à une fête est une soirée à
un dîner ça c'est la première
observation qui est à faire il y a la
question de l'art et puis il ya la
question de celui qui la porte et dans
quelles circonstances ils considèrent
qu'il faudra qu'il apprenne ou pas donc
je trouve que c'est un élargissement du
riddick et qui est intéressant mais je
doute fort que ce soit une pratique
systématique de tous les fonctionnaires
de côte les dispositions depuis juillet
2016 ont été assouplies quant au port de
larmes hors service puisque suite à
l'attentât notamment de magnanville les
policiers avaient l'autorisation de
porter leur arme en tout temps et en
tout lieu
sauf que cette disposition n'était pas
applicable dans tous les établissements
recevant du public ce qui était pour
nous un non sens
d'abord par rapport à des exemples bien
connu on pense au bataclan par exemple
où l'un des terroristes avait été
neutralisé par une arme individuelle
d'un collègue qui était intervenu hills
aurait pu être d'ailleurs un scénario
qui était tout à fait exploitables si
des policiers avaient été à l'intérieur
armés
c'est une disposition intéressante dans
le cadre opérationnel et dans le cadre
de la sécurité aussi des agents hors
service en armes ils cuisent discret
c'est quelque chose qui effectivement ne
nous a pas échappé il y à des
dispositifs et des étuis qui sont plutôt
discrets mais c'est vrai vous avez
raison le 6 joueurs et plus volumineux
par exemple un glock c'est pour ça qu'on
avait demandé d'ailleurs à la direction
générale de la police nationale d'avoir
la possibilité et l'opportunité de
choisir aussi son arme dans le cadre du
travail
tous les policiers ne font pas une
déclaration systématique pour avoir le
port de l'ain en service d'abord c'est
l'objet d'une déclaration individuelle
et ensuite cette déclaration
individuelle doit être corroborés par
l'obligation de 3-2 mentaires de
formation continue sur une année
glissante les freins à l'adoption
ça va être la sagesse des parlementaires
et les arguments si on vous répète
schématiser les arguments favorables ou
au port d'armes des fonctionnaires de
police en service
c'est effectivement la possibilité pour
des fonctionnaires de reprise dans
certaines situations d'intervenir
immédiatement à leur propre initiative
d'un autre côté la partie qui peut
susciter des réserves
c'est d'une part que en fonctionnaires
de police
isolé seul donc dans des preuves ou
ailleurs qui est repéré par des
individus de désagréable va se trouver
en difficulté parce qu'il va pas se
servir de son arme contre des individus
qui n'en n'ont pas et ils risquent de le
thème en difficulté donc plus que cet
article 25 apporte incontestablement une
possibilité de solutions à certains
problèmes d'emploi marginaux mais d'un
autre côté le pareils et comporter des
risques qui à mon sens sont
superfétatoire engrossée par maintenir
là où il pourrait y avoir difficulté et
c'est déjà arrivé notamment
rappelez-vous en 2011 avec le cas d'un
policier qui intervient sur une
agression au couteau à l'armé blanche de
trois individus par rapport à un jeune
homme et qui en fait se fait subtiliser
son arme se fait tirer dessus
d'ailleurs et échapper
à la mort de justesse parce que les
individus mineurs n'ont pas hésité à
faire feu sur le policier mais ça c'est
aussi un problème d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'impunité qui a installé la
désinhibition de la violence et qui a
installé aussi la non peur du policier
quand il est en action de police
et surtout je dirais lane ont peur des
sanctions pénales qui peuvent suivre
d'ailleurs il faut arrêter
d'infantiliser aussi le policier et le
policier quand même quelqu'un qui est
formé à une formation initiale même s'il
ya beaucoup pas dire effectivement sur
cette formation continue des agents tout
au long de la carrière en tout cas dans
le cadre de la remet en service
je peux vous garantir que les trois tirs
sont surveillés de très près par
l'administration et que lorsque vous
n'avez pas vos trois tirs et ben vous
avez l'obligation de remettre au
râtelier larmes et vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de la porter au service